it's what everyone had suspected for
years but finally video proof
mexico's authorities planted evidence in
the biggest disappearance case in the
country for decades
when 43 students were pulled off buses
by municipal police on the night of 26
september 2014 in guerrero state they're
never seen again the public demanded
answers where were they who else was
involved in their disappearance
under pressure mexican authorities came
up with what they called the historic
truth
this drone video shows it as a setup
these tiny figures are mexican marines
heading into the kokula rubbish dump
guerrero on 27 november 2014 close to
where the students disappeared one of
their trucks blocks access to the site
they stopped for a while lingering where
later bullet shells will be conveniently
found by federal investigators then they
move to a different part of the dump
three white bags appear beside them they
light a fire the three bags disappear
present for at least part of this day
say the independent expert was mexico's
then attorney general jesus murillo
fast forward 11 days muriyu kram will
claim in a packed press conference that
the 43 students were shot dead by a
local gang in the cooler dump in the
spot where the marines first stopped
the gang then burnt their bodies he says
where the week before the marines had
lit the fire
it's sad to present these images but
it's our duty to a society that is truly
truly offended
the reason for his fabrication finally a
case which had captured the hearts of
the public and caused unbridled
indignation against the government and
suspicion it could be involved could be
put to rest
that's according to the independent
international experts who arrived in
2014 to investigate
the authorities hid changed information
denied any knowledge of the facts or
where the students were
even before this video they're already
serious doubts about mario karam's
historic truth
not least after videos emerged of
suspects tortured into giving evidence
the key thing about this video is that
it was filmed by a mexican navy drone so
it's almost beyond dispute and it was
then apparently locked in a vault for
more than seven years until a new
administration and current president
andres manuel lopez obrador pushed the
country's intelligence services to hand
over confidential archives like this one
to the independent investigators
but the videos only proved there was a
cover-up the central question is still
unanswered even after all these years
where are the 43 students or at least
their remains
john holman al jazeera mexico city